Super Smash Brothers ultimate is out now
and everyone's here
but despite having every single playable
character from the series past and some
new additions ultimate will still be
adding even more fighters to its roster
piranha plant is coming as a free bonus
to those who register and director
Masahiro Sakurai announced five
additional characters are on the way the
question is who are they well we already
know one Joker from persona 5 persona
itself is almost non-existent on
Nintendo systems which means all bets
are off for those other four DLC
characters so we went ahead and picked
the four we most want to see some fan
favorites like Gino and King Hippo are
already in the game of spirits while
others like Isaac and waluigi appear as
support characters that doesn't mean
they can't be DLC characters but you
won't find them on this list let's smash
[Applause]
we're gonna take a big swing right off
the bat with kiri you from the Yakuza
series because if Street Fighter and
Final Fantasy can get in on the fun
why not Sega is already on board with
Bayonetta and Sonic the red-light
district if Camaro Cho would make for an
interesting stage - but how would cure
you actually play well the Yakuza games
are full of combat with street toughs
and Yakuza thugs so we know he can fight
Yakuza zero and coulomb II also let you
change up cure use techniques with
different styles brawler is about
throwing punches and kicks beasts is
about using objects in the environment
and rush is about speed sounds a lot
like Schalke's Minato Arts huh these let
you accent his speed attack and other
stats battling with environmental
objects also brings to mind snake style
of using various weapons
couple that with Yakuza's trademark
finishers and you've got a recipe for a
final smash I can to little max Giga Mac
Smash Brothers already has plenty of
tag-teaming characters like the ice
climbers in pokemon trainer but at Banjo
and Kazooie were to join the battle they
definitely take cues from tuck hunt as
banjo maneuvers around the battlefield
kazooie could fire off eggs drill attack
with her beak and fly upward for a
recovery move each dlc fighter will
include a music track and stage and the
banjo series is chock full of delightful
tunes paired with imaginative levels
from treasure trove Cove to hellfire
peaks but of course this begs the
question if microsoft owns rare now
could Banjo and Kazooie even appear in
the game xbox boss phil spencer already
confirmed on Twitter that he'd supported
puzzle based characters don't really
exist in Smash beyond dr. Mario and
that's exciting it means there's a
potential for a unique fighter in
Professor Layton his trusty magnifying
glass or fashionable top hat could be
used to Bop enemies in sense his
adventures hail from the D s and 3ds
there's potential here for some
touchscreen inspired moves smash already
shows it's possible with the brain Age
support character as for where he'd
throw down the Layton games also lend
themselves to interesting stages from
st. Mystere in the curious village to
the
were involved in miracle mask and just
because it'd be funny to see it would be
pretty rad if Layton could run over the
competition on a regular bike like Wario
does with his motorcycle we'll wrap it
up with a very nintendo choice captain
toad got his own adventure on Wii U then
got an improved one on switch to give
people another chance to experience it
unlike regular toad who just pops up to
help feature Daisy captain toad is a
more proactive fellow who could slam on
his opponents with a heavy backpack
slapped them around with his pickaxe and
throw turnips his companion toadette
would make for a great palette swap - a
la Bowser jr. in the Koopalings as for
his home stage any number of the
isometric stages could be turned into a
level that shifts perspectives every few
moments
it could even be based on one of his
many minecart rides and those are our
picks for the last 4 DLC smash
characters let us know your top picks in
the comments below and remember that you
can always find tons of Super Smash
Brothers ultimate gameplay and tips on
gamespot
[Applause]
[Music]